but if we take off Master Chief's and
masking reveals that he's like his total
Native American guy I wanted to be
removed and it'd be a Steve Buscemi the
entire time how great would that be
crooked teeth hello guys I'm Ryan right
I'm Dan cyber Dan and I go check out the
halo 5 launch gameplay trailer let's do
this sexy thing that we got going on
right now I'm excited cause it's gonna
determine whether or not I start saving
up for a ex bone or not well I mean one
of many reasons you're a youtuber with
more than 6,000 followers you have at
least half of the money available to buy
and halo 5 as you mean like the $2 yeah
dude
youtubers make way more money talk to
that man
smart and lock spot is that enough years
with only to know the truth
once this is over after all we have done
they will order you to kill us for your
new drugs stopping everything online
the last 72 hours sonic colonies had
experienced identical events massive
destruction opening you know he was
supposed to bring them that's for like
odd million
negative infinity
1 1 7 - this is your one change - come
on
boom my the job to do no monetization on
this video people
Kosar
yes
oh you want me
back
and maybe overall
Wow
that's twice over Kelly now
hashtag on eating Xboxes limited-edition
bundle got a hunt that truth hunt that
truth haunt that [ __ ] and well he's on
a [ __ ] Master Chief because he is the
exact opposite of yeah I know he would
just did even though he's not real he
could still kick my ass he would come
through the screen and punch you in the
face
he's like Chuck Norris in a lot of ways
he's given you the met nummy mugs right
now my god hugs I screwed up the to put
up them fisticuffs hey hey I just want
to give kudos to the trailer first off
for making a fun halo 5 trailer because
there already was halo 5 trailer halo
shows was so [ __ ] serious so it's nice
to get like a refreshing like this is
about having fun we've been watching
halo 5 trailers for a while yes you have
Dan yes we have do you remember those
days I do is this a clip show now could
we make it a clip show yeah where you
ate some of the best moments best throw
regions we watched a lot of the trailers
and a lot of them were like oh my god
the truth what is the truth
yeah even Master Chief has gone rogue
and from that one I'm just like I'm
ready to shoot dudes again which is like
always been halo Jam it's like one dude
one gun everybody dies and every cool
action story I'm gonna try to sing where
I look at the camera the whole time and
never at you every cool action star you
know any tubers do that or they're like
I'm talking to you but I'm looking
directly at a trial of action stories
like this our hero has gone I mean we
just got mission impossible 5 rogue
nation right you know and I like those
stories of you know the hero who we've
seen before now they've gone rogue
because they have a bigger mission
something much more grand than what they
can assign him for that he has to kind
of go outside of the law which is gonna
be really interesting because like up
until now Master Chief like when he says
hey I'm gonna go do this thing everyone
goes yeah [ __ ] yeah I go do yeah like
what exactly did he do to whoever to be
like no [ __ ] what he has to say
he had sex with his boss's daughter
there we go he Master Chief that [ __ ]
oh yeah the car is that was pretty good
Halo and Call of Duty had this
reputation of kind of copying each other
or something like that it tends to
happen like a copy hey that leaked up
you call it duty this does kind of have
like an advanced warfare kind of vibe to
it it's already too technologically
advanced from the beginning of the story
mm-hmm but I feel like they managed to
amplify it way more with a lot of the
cool gameplay footage they were able to
give us I feel like Halo and Call of
Duty like especially in their prime
which would be like Halo 3 and modern
warfare 2 or like at least for me that
was the prime of those two series very
very much like I love halo know I love
Call of Duty those were the two going at
each other they started borrowing stuff
from each other like uh halo start
taking upgrading things I can't think of
a Call of Duty thing that oh um there
was like something distinctive that Call
of Duty took from Halo and I can't
remember where it is now you could play
as Jesus and call it yes you can't in
Halo because Jesus has a halo point
being is I mean like these guys keep
building off each other and so like it's
almost through competition and even
though they're borrowing ideas from each
other the games are still getting better
and so the only person that really
benefits is you know us the players
absolutely as long as they don't like
totally botched and add like 50,000
glitches like they plan to add glitches
every glitch in every game was designed
by the people behind the game that's
[ __ ] conspiracy
that's [ __ ] Dan that's [ __ ]
you're making a mockery of a true gamer
such as myself someone who hardcore
games all the time dude I will own you
on Megaman X oh really yeah you will
only on Megaman has taught the dinosaur
hunter to rock yeah all right so I guess
we're doing a speedrun of megaman x
competitively and we'll top it off with
twin dragons okay mm-hmm-hmm a little
bit of ass try to cut the arcade anyway
guys thanks for tuning in to the Chanel
if you're new to it subscribe today and
become a red
Danis oh nothing about that is good
nah you reject the anus there's a lot of
fecal matter in there no matter how
clean you get it and you can check out
dansgaming channel where he does gaming
become a cyber nugget let me say it's
cyber not cyber not it's not hardened
Seibert I like cyber nugget better
no one's gonna want to be a cyber nugget
at share it's making me hungry right
black Phoenix Studios uh this guy I want
to give a shout out yes four shot a long
time ago I want to give him a shout-out
because he always leaves comments I'm
like practically every video I enjoy
reading the comments that he actually
leaves and it's like making like really
most common [ __ ] god but those guys are
eyes guys ok enough I don't mean it in
that way I mean that black Phoenix
studios is a wonderful studio that
produces many great african-american
films people like Martin Luther King um
Obama
do you not know that many Denzel
Washington yeah a true actor story
Michael Doug Frederick Douglas okay yeah
there's one other lady did mana peanut
butters and that's um that's another
Washington no uh-uh
I know Harriet Tubman yeah there you go
I'm smart she's gonna be on the $20 bill
so check out them really yeah oh sweet
yeah
thanks Obama I wouldn't have known that
if it wasn't for black Phoenix studios
Jesus